[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Thank you
guys so much for having me.
SPEAKER: Yeah, we're
excited to have you.
So would love to just learn
a little bit more about
Mike, the kid from
Pittsburgh, turning
into Chef Michael Solomonov,
the James Beard Award winner.
Did you always know
that this was something
that you were going to be?
Did you always
want to be a chef?
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: No, I was a
really, really difficult eater
as a kid, ironically.
And I was going to be--
I wanted to be an
actor when I was a kid.
I wanted to be a photographer.
I went to college
briefly with the intent
of getting into photography.
And then ended up only
smoking pot, and snowboarding,
and dropping out of college.
SPEAKER: Nice.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: And then
I moved back to Israel.
My family and I had moved--
I was born in Israel,
grew up in Pittsburgh,
and then we moved back
when I was, like, 15.
So I dropped out of school,
and moved back to Israel,
and walked up and down the
main street in the town
that we lived in, in this little
town called Kfar Saba, which
is north of Tel Aviv.
And just asked people in very
broken Hebrew and English
if they needed somebody
to work for them.
And I got a job in a bakery.
And that's where
I started cooking.
SPEAKER: Amazing.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Yeah.
SPEAKER: And from
that bakery, what were
your biggest lessons learned?
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV:
Well, I wasn't
used to working and working
hard or working legitimately.
So I learned a lot about--
I mean, probably the most
important lessons of my life
happened there.
I couldn't talk my way into
anything, because nobody there
cared where I really came from.
They were happy at that
time to have not only
an immigrant worker, but also
an immigrant American worker.
It was like a twofer for them.
It was like this status
symbol that they had this guy.
And it was right around the
Clinton, Monica Lewinsky
scandal thing.
So they would be like,
yeah, Bill Clinton, huh?
You know?
And I was like, I don't
know him personally.
And I don't speak any Hebrew.
Can you just tell me what to do?
I learned a lot about
myself and about what
it was like to really
have to work hard.
And everybody there was
from somewhere else.
And culturally, it was
just really exciting.
And it was at the lowest level--
literally, I was taking out
garbage bags full of trash,
scrubbing sheet trays
for 10 hours at a time,
chasing rats around
with a pizza cutter,
and occasionally would
get to do cool stuff.
And I learned Hebrew, and I
learned a little bit of Arabic,
and I learned a bit of Russian.
My family's from
Bulgaria before Israel,
or like half of my family is.
And I learned what the
sort of social cues
of Bulgarian Jewish
immigrants as it
related to everybody
else-- because there
were Venezuelan immigrants.
There was Muslim Arabs.
There were Christian Arabs.
And it was just awesome.
And I remember the owner of the
bakery took me to his house.
And I thought he was making
me lunch or whatever.
And he made me
clean up his garden.
SPEAKER: [LAUGHS]
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: And then
afterwards, we drank coffee.
And he was asking me if I
wanted to close the bakery,
if that would be my new
task that I would enjoy.
The word for bakery in
Hebrew is "ma'afiyah,"
which I thought was "mafia."
So he was having a conversation
with me for 45 minutes,
and I was like, am
I being in the mob?
Like, is that what's
happening right now?
SPEAKER: Is that my
next career move?
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Because
I didn't know that ma'afiyah
meant "bakery."
So I thought I'd
left there with--
SPEAKER: New job.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: --status.
But really, I got a 20-agorat
raise, which is like $0.07.
So I was making the equivalent
of $3 an hour there.
SPEAKER: Awesome.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV:
And it was amazing.
I loved it.
I fell in love with
the camaraderie
and the legitimate work.
And I'd come from this
sort of upper middle class,
middle class background
in the States.
And my values were skewed.
So it was really cool to do
that and to learn something.
And at the bakery, we made
a bunch of cool things.
Challah.
Everybody eats challah.
First of all, nobody
in Israel gives a shit
about carbohydrates at all.
So they don't know
what Atkins is.
Anytime you go over to
someone's house over there,
and they're like,
come over for coffee,
it is like platters
of cakes, right?
And regardless of how
religious you are,
everybody eats challah,
basically, on Fridays.
So I was used to this
alternative subculture
of being a recluse
pothead in the States.
But in Israel,
working in a bakery
means that you're basically
the center of town on Friday.
So we'd go in Friday
morning at 2:00 AM
and make challahs
for like 14 hours.
And every single
person in the town
would come and participate.
So you were part of
something, right?
And then my grandmother,
who was probably like--
I know this is super cliched--
but the reason I
probably love food
or love the heritage of
the food that I cook,
would make bourekas, which
are this Balkan pastry that
come all the way
from medieval Spain
through the Ottoman
Empire to Israel.
And I got to make
thousands of them a day.
And it was like the one thing
that I loved eating as a kid.
And it was the way that I
could relate to my grandmother.
So to be part of something on
this hyper social, but also
hyper spiritual
level was something
I had never really experienced.
SPEAKER: Amazing.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Yeah.
SPEAKER: Real question.
Boureka is filled with spinach,
with cheese, with potato.
What's your favorite filling?
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Feta cheese
with a shitload of sesame
on top--best.
SPEAKER: Cool.
Awesome.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: But all of
them are really, really good.
And they tell the story
of real Israeli cuisine.
And it's fascinating.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Do you guys
want to hear the real story?
SPEAKER: Let's hear it.
You're tempting us.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: OK, good.
And then I'm done
after this, right?
No.
So my grandmother, her
maiden name before Solomonov,
was Toledo, which is
from the town in Spain.
Post-Inquisition, they
peaced out of Spain.
And they brought with
them this laminated dough.
And everyone thinks that the
French puff pastry actually
comes from the Sephardic
Jews in medieval Spain.
So they brought
with them this dough
to the Balkans,
where they settled.
And the Ottomans came
in and took over,
like they did a lot of
the world at that time.
And they started stuffing this
laminated pastry with what
we think is Bulgarian feta.
And then the Bulgarians
overthrew the Ottomans
using Russian
families to help arm
them, which is why my last
name is Solomonov, actually.
Everyone thinks I'm Russian.
I don't speak any Russian.
And in fact, the
last name was Bahar.
But to honor the
Russian families that
helped arm these
Bulgarians in Varna,
they all took
Russian last names.
And then in 1948, they
all moved to Israel,
bringing with them this
savory pastry, which is now
on every single street
corner in Israel,
which is awesome, right?
SPEAKER: Yeah, great story.
So given that you had
a stint in Israel,
came back to the
States, how do you
think that kind
of back-and-forth
has influenced your food today?
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV:
I actually think,
going back-- so I didn't move
to Israel to become a chef.
I just ended up working there.
And then I worked at a
little cafe after the bakery.
And I was like, wow, creating
things with my hands is fun.
I like the intensity.
I like the people-pleasing.
I'm going to become a chef.
And it wasn't my intention
to cook Israeli food.
I moved back to the States,
and went to culinary school,
and then worked in a bunch
of European restaurants
or whatever.
And I thought that's what--
at that time in the '90s, or
the late '90s, early 2000s,
everybody would go to school
or work and then go to Europe.
And it was either San
Sebastian, Spain or France.
That's kind of where
everybody was going.
And that's just what
I thought I would do.
And then I ended up not.
I ended up going back to
visit my family in Israel.
One of many things happened.
And I just sort of was--
I don't know.
Sitting down at a
restaurant and having
20 different little
dishes come out
that represent 20
different countries,
and the sort of music of it
all, and the choreography,
and the live fuel, and
everything over charcoal,
and spices that
you've never heard
of that represent the
spice trade, the Silk Road,
2,000 years of
post-Babylon diaspora,
Palestinian cooking from the
West Bank, from the Levant,
from Gaza, the
Shabbat dinners that
include 100 different
cultures all mushed together,
it was like, why do I
need to go to France?
Why do I need to go to Spain?
At that time, ironically, tapas
was a big thing in Philly.
And I was like, well, people
understand small plates
because of tapas, which is
funny, because mezze predates
tapas by, like, 2,000 years.
But whatever.
And I think that while that was
happening, people in Israel,
instead of cooks in
Israel going to Europe,
or going to Asia or the States,
and then coming back to Israel
to open up French restaurants or
whatever, they were like, well,
going to have Shabbat dinner at
my grandparents' means Polish,
Moroccan, Yemenite,
and Romanian.
It's all right here.
I don't need to go
anywhere else for it.
So we decided to open
an Israeli restaurant.
And we didn't know
what that meant,
because everyone was like--
what do you think?
When somebody says
there's a restaurant,
they're like, falafel, right,
or shawarma, or hummus, which--
we would have made a lot
more money had we just
opened up those places.
So we had to convince people
and answer the question--
everyone was like,
isn't it political
to open an Israeli restaurant?
And I'm like, I don't know.
I'm Israeli.
I think that's kind of
a big, broad question.
So we decided to
open what people call
a modern Israeli restaurant.
Even though we cook
everything over charcoal
and make bread in a
wood-burning oven.
The cooking methods
are quite primitive.
But the idea of this
global Israeli food
going to different places and
being sort of reinterpreted
is what I think makes it modern.
SPEAKER: Interesting.
Love that.
So not only did you have
an uber-successful Israeli
restaurant.
You also have a donut empire.
You have a few cookbooks.
How do you decide what
ideas are worth sticking
to or really worth pursuing?
I'm sure you get,
in your head, a lot
of different concepts, ideas.
What makes something
worth pursuing to you?
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: I think
that's a really difficult
question to answer, because
I think that as much as one
can strategize-- the secret
to any of this success
is having a brilliant
business partner or partners,
which I've been lucky to have.
I think that you have to make
a lot of really bad decisions.
You don't wake up in the
morning, and you're like,
we're going to have
a donut empire.
What really happened is Zahav
almost closed its first year.
We opened another restaurant.
So we opened a modern Israeli
restaurant in 2008 right
after Wachovia, AIG went under.
I was in drug rehab.
And the Phillies were
winning the World Series,
which is awesome if
you have a restaurant
or bar with a TV in it, not if
you have an Israeli restaurant.
And the elections
were happening.
Nobody wanted to go out and eat.
And the economy
was falling apart.
And when you're doing chopped
Israeli salad in February
in eastern Pennsylvania,
it's a little bit
difficult for the
customer, I guess,
to understand what
was happening.
So we almost went under.
It was an awful year
for many reasons.
And then we decided to
open a barbecue restaurant,
thinking that it would be low
labor, low cost, low tech.
All of those things were wrong.
We opened, brisket
was $1.90 a pound.
When we sold the restaurant,
brisket was at $5.00 a pound.
Smoking meat is
very difficult. We
were doing it like
Texas style, which
is closer to the Jewish
brisket that we grew up with.
Most people don't like that.
Most people, actually,
go anywhere in the South,
have barbecue once, and think
that that is what barbecue is.
So we didn't have pulled
pork for the first two years
even though everyone was like--
SPEAKER: Where's
the pulled pork?
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV:
--where's the pulled pork?
I love pulled pork.
And we're like, no, no,
no, they don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
The reality is
you need to listen
to what your customers want.
And it doesn't matter what the
tradition is, because tradition
in Texas is different
just like it
is when you make
pasta in Piedmont,
depending on what side of
the street you live on.
And the other thing is we
weren't emotionally invested
into what it was.
It didn't mean
the same as Zahav.
So we started a donut
empire because we
had two restaurants that
were going to go under,
that were huge.
My partner, Steve, and I
met three other people.
We all threw in a very small
amount of money, whatever
we were kind of willing
to lose at that time,
because we wanted to do a new
project, and we were bored,
and the big-box restaurants in
Philly were going to kill us.
So we found a
600-square-foot restaurant
with three other people.
Two of them brought the first
wave of fancy coffee to Philly.
The other person was
a social media whiz.
Steve and I knew food.
And we opened Federal
Donuts with, like, $30,000.
And then on day two--
well, day one and day two, we
ran out of donuts in an hour,
and we had people standing
in line for chicken
at 11:00 AM, when
we started at noon.
And we were like, oh, we might
actually be on to something.
So it was kind of like we had
nothing else left to lose,
and we ended up with a donut
empire a few years later.
SPEAKER: Awesome.
And what made you decide to
do donuts and fried chicken?
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV:
[LAUGHS] I don't know.
But the two--
SPEAKER: Just sounded good.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Yeah,
donut, fried chicken, coffee
are the three major food
groups in Philadelphia.
So no, the guys that
we had partnered with
wanted to do donuts, because
nobody was really doing donuts.
And I think at the
time, I was just
eating a shitload of
Korean fried chicken.
And we were like, we'll have
one piece of equipment, which
will be a fryer, and we could
do donuts and fried chicken,
which it turns out
that donuts don't
taste very good after you've
fried a bunch of chicken
in them.
So we bought another
piece of equipment.
SPEAKER: Got it.
Got it.
So how was writing a cookbook?
What does that
process look like?
How do you decide, this
is what I want to do?
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV:
Well, it is rough.
Again, this is where
it's very important
to have an intelligent
business partner that
can write a cookbook.
But I think for
the Zahav cookbook,
it's something that we
wanted to do for years.
And it took us about
five years to figure out
what our role was in being this
conduit from Israel to the US,
or to the Western
market, or whatever.
Or figure out what our--
to be comfortable with the role
that we had in Israeli cuisine.
So it took a long time.
And there were a lot of moments
where we could have done it
differently or maybe a little
bit easier, which we didn't do.
Thank god.
And my business partner, Steve,
who had never written anything
professionally ever, after
toying with the idea of ghost
writers, was like,
I'm just going
to try to write a head
note, which he did.
And then he was like, I'm
going to write a chapter.
And then two years later, he
won two James Beard Awards
for writing this book,
which was awesome,
including Book of the Year.
So Zahav was a
very personal book,
and it was a book that
the restaurant deserved,
the movement that we
were a part of deserved.
And it was something that was
a very-- it's a personal book.
It's not just an
Israeli cookbook written
by an Israeli cookbook author.
It's sort of like
our heart and soul.
And it's like my family
and this sort of look
into Israel with your toe
in Israel and in the States.
The Federal Donuts book
was just kind of fun.
And we wanted to do it.
And it's a little bit
silly, and there's
a workout routine in it.
SPEAKER: There is.
I did see it.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: I
work out at a boxing gym.
And my trainer is
part of the cookbook.
So it's great.
You do exercises with fried
chicken, squats and stuff.
And they work.
And then we're working
on our third book
right now, which is the next--
it's like the prequel to Zahav--
SPEAKER: Very cool.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV:
--which required
us to be in Israel, shooting
and eating for like 10 days.
SPEAKER: Wow.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: We had 82
meals in, like, eight days.
AUDIENCE: Wow.
SPEAKER: Wow.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: So we needed
to do a lot of chicken exercise
after that.
SPEAKER: I was going to say--
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV:
And that is good.
I'm hoping that we
don't have to do anymore
cookbooks after this.
SPEAKER: Three and done.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV:
But it's great.
It's amazing to
publish something.
We always thought that
the digital cookbook
would be the thing.
There is something about
sitting in your bathrobe,
reading a cookbook at your
coffee table that is amazing.
And there is something
about your kids
seeing it and recognizing
it, and having
coffee stains, or hummus
stains, or whatever variety
of food stains that you
have on the cookbook that
is special and personal.
SPEAKER: Absolutely.
Definitely.
I know I can say I do
like reading my hardcover.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: What
kind of food products
do you have stuck on your book?
SPEAKER: You know, tea.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Tea?
SPEAKER: On the inside.
But that's about it.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: That's
a really safe answer.
SPEAKER: I don't know.
Any other good food products
stuck on your cookbooks
in the audience?
Good idea?
No?
AUDIENCE: Lemon-garlic paste.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Lemon-garlic
paste is a good one.
SPEAKER: We should do stain
removers for cookbooks.
Next product.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: I don't know.
Or we should do bookmarks that
are like a piece of steak that
you just, like--
SPEAKER: Yes, exactly.
So you're a busy guy.
You have multiple restaurants,
multiple cookbooks, traveling.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Yes.
SPEAKER: How do you
keep it all in balance?
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV:
I am not the person
to talk to about balance.
SPEAKER: OK.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: I don't think
that there's ever an ideal.
I don't think that
there's ever perfect.
I think that you always
have to prioritize.
And I think that could be
hour to hour or day to day.
I don't think looking
too far ahead--
we write these--
I have these goals
for the next year.
And then after
day two, I'm like,
this is the stupidest
freaking thing ever.
And it doesn't really
work like that.
And I think that there's
always short-term and long-term
happiness, and that these
long-term goals that we have
are--
they're important to have,
but they are never accurate.
And I think they always
should be changing.
I don't know.
Not very good about balance--
SPEAKER: That's OK.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: --to
answer your question.
SPEAKER: We're always
striving here at Google
to have better balance.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: There's
no such thing as perfect,
yet we're always
trying to achieve it.
And I think that going
into it and being cognizant
of the whole thing and being
cognitive about the way
that you try to attain it
is the most important thing.
You know?
SPEAKER: Totally.
Totally.
Very cool.
Well, we'll start opening
up the floor to questions,
but before we do, I have a
little quick-fire for you.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Oh.
SPEAKER: But you kind of
already answered my first one.
What is your 2018 New
Year's resolution?
I know you said you
don't really have one.
But if you had to pick one.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: I
want to drink more water.
SPEAKER: Cool.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: I want to
sleep closer to seven hours
a night.
I want to read more
and meditate more.
I want to land a
backflip on a snowboard.
SPEAKER: Cool.
Very cool.
I like-- they're all great.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: One of
those things might not happen.
SPEAKER: I was going
to say, very ambitious.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Yeah,
I want to get my kids
to eat more decent food.
And we have a couple of
very exciting projects.
One of them is super
personal, and I really
want that to open well.
SPEAKER: Cool.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Yeah.
And how do you pick where
you want to expand to?
I know you have
restaurants in Philly.
You have restaurants in Miami.
You have Dizengoff
here in New York.
What kind of process do you go
through when you're thinking
about where you want to expand?
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV:
Well, I think we
have these sort of grand plans.
But I think that a lot
of what we depend on
is our human resource and
the way that our team grows.
In hospitality,
you need to accept
that you are a slave to your
employees, and your team,
and to your customers.
And if you don't
find joy in that,
it's not a good
business to get into.
And basically, we
just have to listen
to our customers, and
our guests, and our team,
and kind of figure out--
the convergence of
those two relationships
determines kind of
where we go next.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
No, I like that.
So what's your biggest cooking
or kitchen hack, or trick?
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Trick.
I mean, I have a lot of tricks.
SPEAKER: OK, cool.
What's your favorite?
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: That's
a very mysterious answer.
I don't know.
Be more specific.
SPEAKER: Is there a way to
cut an onion that no one knows
that you've figured out?
Or turning on a
certain temperature
for a certain sauce?
Like, any hacks
or tricks that you
could share with the broader,
non-professional chefs?
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Well, we
refer to this in our book,
but the secret of our hummus
is very fluffy tehina.
We blend whole bulbs of
garlic with lemon juice
and let it sit for,
like, 10 minutes,
so it mellows the garlic.
And then pass and
strain the whole thing.
So it's kind of a step.
You don't have to peel garlic.
And the bulb and the skin are
actually pretty delicious.
We add that to raw tehina and
then whip it with ice water.
And you end up with
this amazing sauce.
The other trick is
that when you puree
whole bulbs of garlic
and lemon juice
for about 10 seconds, the way
that all the product suspends,
it looks like a milkshake.
And if you're working next
to somebody that you dislike,
you're like, try this
milkshake I made.
And then they drink it--
[BLOWS MESSY RASPBERRY] [GROANS]
SPEAKER: Great hack.
Perfect trick.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: So you
decide which trick you like.
SPEAKER: [LAUGHS] OK.
So if you had to pick
one, donuts or hummus?
[LAUGHS]
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Cut, cut.
I don't know.
They're both fantastic.
SPEAKER: OK.
The one food you
can't live without?
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV:
I love raw carrots.
SPEAKER: Nice.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: But
I think that legumes are
pretty delicious and healthy.
Peanut butter,
have to have that.
Oh my god, I have to
have peanut butter.
Cucumbers are really good.
But when I cook,
I need a shitload
of parsley and lemon
juice on everything.
SPEAKER: Cool.
What's your favorite
restaurant in New York?
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV:
It's kind of a toss-up.
Eleven Madison Park
is obviously amazing.
Shuko, which is a great
sushi restaurant, is awesome.
A restaurant in Williamsburg
called Traif, which is great.
One of my good friends runs it.
Where else?
Momofuku Ssam Bar
is still amazing.
L&B Pizza in Brooklyn.
Really good tomato pie.
I don't know.
It's kind of hard.
This is terrible.
But I'm up in New York
once a week or whatever.
And there's a pizza
place in Penn Station
that I eat out at the most.
SPEAKER: All right,
pizza in Penn Station.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV:
You can wash it
down with a lukewarm cup
of coffee from the kiosk
next door.
SPEAKER: You're just
missing the hot dog.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: [SCOFFS]
There's something in Philly.
I can't remember what it's
called, and I've never had it.
And you take a cheesesteak
from Jim's, which
is on South Street, and put
it inside of a slice of pizza
from Lorenzo's, and you
roll it up and eat it.
So you were saying hot dog.
But I guess you could wrap a
hot dog with a slice of pizza
and eat it.
SPEAKER: Yeah, the
New York version.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: You got to
make sure the coffee is hot,
so you can shoot it down
your throat, you know?
SPEAKER: All right.
Food competition.
So what's your favorite food
destination besides Israel?
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: I think
that we live in this great--
this is a frustrating,
stupid-ass answer
that I'm going to give you.
But I think that
everywhere right now
is like a foodie town.
And I think that we are
on the cusp of people
really getting a chance
to express themselves
and where they're from.
And although there's tons
of xenophobia and alienation
happening all over
the world, people now
have this grassroots way
of telling their story.
And I think that
everywhere you go
has got these
immigrant populations.
Everywhere you go
in the world have
got people that have
made this living
generation after generation from
preparing food and hospitality.
So I like going anywhere.
I like going anywhere.
I like going in holes in
the walls in any city.
I think it's amazing.
We were just talking
about South Florida.
And when I learned
how to cook, I
went to culinary school
in West Palm Beach.
And there were three kinds
of restaurants there.
And now you can go
anywhere and figure out
where people are from.
You can go to any
random road in Florida,
and just take it, and
find a little place
that has arepas, or
the best Cuban coffee,
or great Thai food.
And it's just--
I don't know.
I don't think there's a place
in the country that doesn't
have a great food scene.
I don't often eat at
fancy restaurants,
mostly because I can't sit
for more than 45 minutes
without having an
anxiety attack.
But I think that--
I don't know.
I think anywhere
is pretty great.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV:
Anywhere Queens.
I just get on a
train and go out.
And god, what is the stop that
has got the great Indo-Paki--
do you guys know?
Or what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Jackson Heights.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Yes,
Jackson Heights, man.
And then there's
amazing dumplings.
I mean, it's freaking awesome.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Yeah.
SPEAKER: Very cool.
So last question.
Proudest moment of your career.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV:
That is a good one.
Do you want to actually hear it?
SPEAKER: Yeah, let's hear it.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: OK.
So we've won a bunch
of great awards.
I won the James Beard
Award for Best Chef:
Mid-Atlantic on Israeli
Independence Day in 2011
and then Outstanding Chef
again on Independence Day.
And it was amazing, amazing.
But I received a letter--
I'm going to do--
I'm doing this right now.
I'm going to read something, OK?
SPEAKER: Do it.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: I've
got to find it on my phone.
Are you guys ready?
SPEAKER: Yeah.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV:
So here it is.
"Dear Michael, my
name is Reem, and I'm
the author of the book you
are holding in your hands."
And the book was "The
Palestinian Table."
"I still remember
eating at Zahav
back in 2008 when I was
a student at Wharton.
There was a dish of
freekeh topped with chicken
at the time, and I felt so
satisfied and so nostalgic
when I tasted it."
And then in parentheses, she
writes, "maybe also a little
jealous that the
best Arabic food
I had tasted since
arriving in Philly
was at an Israeli restaurant."
And then she did the
"semi-colon smile" thing,
which is weird when
somebody writes it out.
But I liked it.
[LAUGHTER]
Because Palestinian
and Israeli, we're
all insecure line cooks
at the end of the day.
And I was like, yeah, we won.
So, "It's been almost
a decade since,
and I just moved back to Philly
with my family from London
this past year.
It's amazing to see what you've
done since I was here last.
To be honest, I wanted
to reach out for a while,
but I hesitated.
Yet when I watched 'In Search
of Israeli Cuisine,'" which was
a documentary I was
in, "this past week,
I realized what a genuine,
fun, curious person you are.
And it reaffirmed my
desire to reach out to you
and get to know you.
I believe food can help
start a conversation where
nothing else has been able to.
And I hope my book is a
testament to that fact.
As it happens, the
photographer who shot my book
is Israeli, Dan Perez.
And the whole process
of working together
reaffirmed to me how the
human spirit can rise
above our muddled politics.
So I just wanted to
share my book with you
and say thank you for the
inspiration you've been.
You certainly don't
need my cookbook,
but I do hope you enjoy
looking through it
and maybe find a small piece
of our shared home inside it.
Until we meet in person, I leave
you with my warmest wishes.
Reem."
Yeah.
SPEAKER: That's pretty amazing.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: That was
the best part of my career.
SPEAKER: Wow.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Yup.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Applause for that.
Amazing.
And now you have
it on your phone
and you can always find it.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Or I
can struggle to find it.
But it's there.
Yeah, I think that
that is the best.
I think that that is by far
the most important thing.
And we have goals in
2018, which may or may not
be harder than landing a
backflip on a snowboard,
but we'll see.
SPEAKER: Who knows.
TBD.
That's awesome.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Thanks.
SPEAKER: Well, we'll open
up the room for questions
from the audience.
Yeah.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming.
I've eaten at Dizengoff next
door, and it was fantastic.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Thank you.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Not only
is the hummus really good,
but the pita bread
is also the best.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV:
Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: Well, it's
the best that I've had.
I haven't been to Israel.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Your check
is in the mail, my friend.
Thank you very much.
[LAUGHTER]
You took off your
Dizengoff shirt
before coming over here, right?
AUDIENCE: That's right.
I don't know.
I just snuck in here.
I like making hummus at
home, but it's hard for me
to make a pita
that's that great.
Do you have any tips?
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: I do.
Actually, in the book, we have--
I'm not just saying
this so you buy a book.
Who wants a book?
No, uh--
SPEAKER: You get a
book, you get a book.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV:
Here's what you do.
Just steal hers, take a
picture of the recipe, and go.
We have an easy way to
make it using a home oven,
and using the
broiler, basically,
and a cookie tray upside down.
Good pita is a few things.
It is not overworking
the dough, and it
is super hot
contact with an oven
to get good oven spring
to make the pocket.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's
kind of like-- it
sounds like, basically, pizza
but no toppings, in a way,
right?
Like, I think about the same
thing when baking a pizza.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Yeah.
Like, a less marketable pizza.
But pizza, you've got
a little bit more,
because you need a
little bit of crust,
whereas the perfect
pita, despite a lot
of the store-bought pita that
we have here in the States,
should be really pliable,
so you can scoop and wipe,
and also needs to
hold up, so you
can make a sandwich with it,
drive a car, talk on the phone,
and smoke a cigarette
at the same time, which
is the test of a perfect pita.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
I will test for that.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: In the
book, we have a great recipe.
AUDIENCE: With trends like
Yelp, Instagram, and podcasts,
what are some of
the pros and cons
that you see in these,
as a restaurant owner?
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: I think
that every industry is always
changing.
I think the restaurant industry
is definitely no exception.
And I think that people
hate on Yelp, for example.
And everyone-- it's
like, ooh, Yelpers.
But I mean, if I go
to a table at Zahav,
and I'm like, hey, covered in
flour, bringing the pita over,
and I'm like, what do you think?
You're going to be like,
oh, my god, it's great.
Thank you so much.
And then you're going to
leave and you're going
to be like, that place sucks.
You know?
And the good thing about Yelp
is even though sometimes I
lose sleep over
how brutally honest
it can be, it's one of the
only ways to get real feedback.
So a lot of people hate on Yelp.
The truth is we read--
I read-- everybody in my
company reads our Yelp reviews
every single day.
And we respond to every
single one of them.
And we take them
all very seriously.
So it's annoying when--
it's annoying, because I want
people to like everything
that I do.
The reality is we're in the
most subjective industry,
and we're trying to
please, I don't know,
like thousands of people a week
that all have different taste
buds.
And there's no real
way to do that.
But the other things--
I mean, it's just a function of
what it is that we do, right?
The industry and
environment that you're in
is only about
progressive ingenuity.
And I think restaurants
are exactly the same.
And trends are happening
now because people
are interested in food.
And media and communications
are just out there.
And having an Instagram account
with thousands of followers
coming to the restaurant,
and taking a picture,
and posting it is sometimes
just as important as a review
from a critic, which
is crazy a little bit.
But it's just the way it goes.
So I think that it's
kind of exciting.
I can't wait to see what's
next and the way that--
I don't know.
There's a lot of things
happening at the same time
right now.
We've got environment,
labor, all these sort
of topics and issues.
And the way that technology
and ingenuity, I think,
are going to help put things
in the right direction.
And to be part of it in one way
or another is pretty exciting.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I watched the
documentary on Netflix,
and my husband and I were
grinning from ear to ear,
because it was so great.
You guys have to watch it.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Question, though.
We noticed that falafel
wasn't really mentioned.
And it's such an
iconic food of Israel
and that region of
the Middle East.
So I'm curious if there was a
specific reason it was omitted
or you guys just had so many
other good subjects it couldn't
be included.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Yeah, I
mean, come to think of it,
I guess you're right.
We ate so much falafel.
I just don't know.
I don't actually know.
The filmmaker Roger
Sherman would probably
answer that better.
But I don't think
there was a reason.
I don't think we
were like, well,
we can't do falafel,
because that's too much--
SPEAKER: Too [INAUDIBLE].
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV:
--too much or whatever.
AUDIENCE: Too controversial.
SPEAKER: [LAUGHS]
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: What
you saw on the film
was like 20% of what we shot.
And we were there for
three and a half weeks,
eating seven times a day.
It was crazy.
So I don't know why there
wasn't a falafel documentary.
There should be.
Only falafel.
AUDIENCE: Is there enough
footage for a Part 2?
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: There
could be footage for Part 2.
I mean, it could go on forever.
And what's funny is that we
shot that five years ago.
I go to Israel at
least once a year.
I obviously go to visit family.
But it's like my job.
I eat all the time.
And most of the places
that we went to I
had not even heard of.
And a lot of places that I
go back to, I don't even--
the country is the
size of New Jersey.
And it's just like you could
not skip a meal or a cuisine
for weeks.
It's just so
gastronomically rich.
But I think that was kind of
the point that we were making.
But I don't know about
the falafel thing.
We should definitely
make a complaint on Yelp
to the filmmaker.
AUDIENCE: It was still great.
Thank you.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Thank you.
If you're a falafel fan too,
you should come to Philly.
We have a good
falafel shop there.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
We've actually been talking
about taking a little day trip.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Do it.
Get the Google bus, or airplane,
or helicopters, and come down.
Yeah, the copter.
AUDIENCE: So first of all, thank
you so much for being here.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV:
Thanks for having me.
AUDIENCE: My mom is
Israeli, actually,
and I definitely connected
with the kind of eclectic food
that I grew up eating,
like from hummus,
obviously, to
schnitzel, to borscht,
to blintzes, to you name
it, by the way of Poland,
I should say.
So obviously, Dizengoff is
kind of a different kind
of hospitality than Zahav.
It's more of a
takeout spot for me.
I'm curious what you think
just in terms of the restaurant
industry about delivery?
Do you think delivery
is the next great thing?
Do you think it's
a necessary evil?
Do you think it's kind of
the downfall of restaurants?
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV:
And we were sort
of touching on this before.
I definitely think
it's the future.
I think that takeout--
I mean, especially in
metropolitan areas,
are the way that we
sort of work, I guess.
I think that delivery makes
the most amount of sense.
And I think figuring out
the way to do that is
sort of the next big thing.
And for us-- and this
goes back to the reason
that we cook Israeli food.
It's my food memories,
the reasons that I cook,
are not because
of a seven-course
or 12-course tasting menu
at a Michelin restaurant.
It's about having the perfect
pita and hummus that make
me want to explode with joy.
And I think that you have
that opportunity with takeout,
with fast casual.
And it definitely is.
And I think, actually, a lot of
places are doing it quite well.
I think there still is
a lot of room for that--
the Dizengoff partnership
here with you all could work.
But I think that that is
definitely the next thing.
AUDIENCE: I guess to
maybe be more specifically
around the actual
kind of texture,
flavor, heat, temperature,
all those things
around the perfect
pita, for example--
how that travels and some of the
challenges that go with that.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: I know.
We're working on that too.
And I think that the
perfect pita, for us,
goes in Styrofoam, sealed.
So we're waiting for somebody--
and maybe in your
free time, guys,
you can start working on this.
There are people using
fungus, actually,
sort of like plastic-esque
fungus that sort of simulates
airtight plastic.
So we need that, because that
is what the perfect pita is.
It is soft, and it is fluffy.
And it doesn't even
have to be warm.
But sealing it is good.
And we do that now.
When we dropped
off pita here, we
brought over these giant
Styrofoam containers
that we reuse.
But as much as I think it would
make a great Instagram video,
we can't drop off one pita with
a giant Styrofoam container,
and open it up.
You know?
What we should do is put a
human being inside of it,
so when you open it up, they
jump out and they're like,
here's your pita,
and they run away.
So that's what we're
going to work on next.
I do think it's kind
of the next big thing.
But I think that goes
for every type of food.
There's so many different
kinds of iconic street food
that people are used to eating
in the street and standing up.
And delivery of it
kind of messes it up.
So yeah.
Hey.
AUDIENCE: Hello?
You briefly mentioned
your business partner.
I think his name was
Steve, and how important it
was to have a good one.
It makes perfect sense.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you
talk a little bit
about how you guys
came to work together,
where you experienced the most
friction with one another,
and how you make decisions
when you inevitably disagree?
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Those
are great questions.
And those are things that we,
after being in business for 10
years, becoming best friends
after being business partners,
you always have to re-examine.
And sometimes they can
be super uncomfortable.
And we're opposite
people, which I
think makes a better product
for our guests and for our team.
He was an investment banker
that hated it from day one.
He was here, working for
Blackstone in the late '90s,
then decided to go to
culinary school at night,
and then opened a
restaurant in Philadelphia,
and then after a short period
of time, got really burned out.
And his wife and I grew
up together in Pittsburgh.
So we met and hung out, and
then started opening restaurants
together.
And I think that the way that
we contradict one another,
it forces a conversation.
And I think that we
ultimately take ourselves
out of the equation,
because you have
to change the narrative if
it's like the two of you that
have everything that you've
ever worked on or invested--
you know, we invest everything
together all the time.
So we have to make
decisions that
are super subjective
but also very objective,
because we're
considering so much.
And I think the back-and-forth
friction is actually
a good thing.
We have to adjust,
basically, and we
have to remember that
we're not the only people
making decisions all the time.
And sometimes they
can be dragged out,
and sometimes they can
be funny and ironic,
and then sometimes
they can breed
probably a very low
level of resentment
until we talk it out.
But I think that we're always
consciously disagreeing
on things.
And I feel like that ends up--
we sort of always have
our eye on the prize.
I don't like it.
I don't like confrontation.
And I am really animated.
And when I get pissed off,
I yell and throw things.
And he is very quiet
and will stare at you
for an hour and a half
until he gets what he wants.
And he's also super intelligent.
And I am what I like to call
emotionally intelligent.
I think that we're
sort of forced
to come up with decisions
together because of that.
And when you have everything
collateralized for bank loans,
you can't just walk away.
And I think that
also, what's been
really funny is, because of
the nature of our industry,
people see me as the guy
that does everything.
Because people like
chefs, because we're
on TV, because we have tattoos,
and because we drop F bombs.
And people love that, and
they think we're creative.
The reality is everything
that I've ever done
has been with Steve.
Like a lot of our
restaurants-- because I
tend to work at Zahav a lot.
We have 14 restaurants.
I don't make decisions
for all of them.
He's got a finance background.
Obviously, when we're
writing business plans,
I'm not the guy that's
like, fuckin' whatever.
[LAUGHTER]
Loan officers don't love
that sort of discussion.
So a lot of what we've had
to do is check our egos.
And every time an
article gets published
that's like Michael
Solomonov's restaurant empire,
I get offended by it.
And I need to sit and
be like, Steve, I'm
so sorry that that has
happened, because it's bullshit,
because we have 250
people that work for us.
Steve and I come
up with everything.
Steve has written three books.
One of them won
two Beard Awards,
including Book of the Year.
And people still look
at my name as the thing.
So a lot of it has to be that
emotional sort of checking.
And in the office,
people go to Steve
and want him to make decisions.
And I'm like, hey, dude,
I'm like a 50% owner
of all these things.
And although I
get lippy and loud
and don't have
business experience,
we've built this together.
So on one hand,
my ego gets hurt.
On the other hand,
his gets hurt.
And we have to sit
and do kumbaya often,
or trust falls with one another,
which are not effective.
You need more than two people.
I think it's awesome.
And I think that he's, for
all intents and purposes,
like my brother.
And we've been to hell and
back and through hell and back
together.
And I love the idea of what--
we've been partners
together for like a decade
and built so much together.
And I think a lot of that
has to do with our resilience
as a team.
So it's good.
But it's hard to work
with other people.
It is not easy.
Most relationships fall apart.
Most egos fall apart.
And the moment you start
believing everything positive
written about you
and take it to heart
is when things do fall apart.
So don't get into the restaurant
business is what I'm saying.
Thanks for your
questions, though.
They were really-- I
hope I answered them.
Hey.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I have a
lighthearted question.
You mentioned one of your
New Year's resolutions
was to have your
kids eat better.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: As a new mom
of a young daughter,
I'm just curious--
like, real talk,
I'm guessing your kids
don't eat dino chicken
nuggets on a random Tuesday.
Maybe they do.
But what is the before?
What are they eating now?
What do you hope
they would eat later?
I'm just curious.
What's the before and
after in your world?
I'm guessing it's
different than mine.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV:
It always changes.
And I think the one constant
is that there is no absolute
and that whenever
you think you're
onto some thing with your
kid, it always changes.
So the things that
they've always enjoyed,
though, have been Asian
noodle soup, which I'm lucky,
because we can do pho.
We can do ramen,
that kind of thing.
Greens and herbs and stuff
are a little bit tricky.
But I think that
bribing them with candy
is what you should do.
[LAUGHTER]
And I'm also not above--
I get a little--
I fly off the handle
and will sometimes
border on being a crazy parent.
And like a little pat on
the back, grab on the neck,
and I'm like, you're
going to eat this.
But I think it's
always a victory.
My oldest son will not eat
a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich, but will eat head-on,
shell-on shrimp tail first.
And I'm like,
dude, you're eating
Szechuan shrimp that are so
spicy, no adult will eat that.
But why won't you
eat Wonder Bread?
And I think what you have to
do is celebrate the shrimp
and then find shrimp all
over the city to go eat.
And then you do it.
But bribing with candy is
definitely the only way
to actually make it work.
And M&M's have these
caramel ones right
now that the kids love.
And that will get them--
they'll eat anything.
SPEAKER: Do you cook
at home a lot for them?
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: That
is the other thing.
I think having them
participate is a huge thing
and being part of it.
And even baby fingers
picking cilantro
leaves that they will
never eat, still exciting,
and they're still
part of that, too.
But I've found smoothies,
you can do a lot.
If you start with a banana
and strawberry, you can--
AUDIENCE: Throw in kale.
Throw in whatever.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Or like
eye of newt or whatever.
You can put anything in there.
As long as it's red and
smells like a banana,
you could put anything in there.
AUDIENCE: It's true.
Yeah.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Like,
gravel if you wanted.
It wouldn't make a difference.
Any other--
SPEAKER: Good to know.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV:
Any other questions?
SPEAKER: Good to know.
Oh.
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: Oh.
Oh, here we go.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Mike.
So you've done a lot of
research for your food, right?
You've been to Israel a lot.
Do you feel you have a
lot more digging to do,
like find all the recipes, going
through all the genealogy, as
much as the food and
recipes have traveled?
Where are you in your
satisfaction level on that?
MICHAEL SOLOMONOV: That
is a great question,
and I am not satisfied.
We have a long way to go.
And I think that--
god, I remembered this middle
school social studies teacher.
I think it was the first--
maybe it was the first history
class I ever took.
And they were like, bullet
point was like, why is it
important to study history?
And it was like, so you can
understand or at least shape
the future, which we've all
come to terms with is bullshit.
But the idea of being able to
do it and figuring out your role
and the sort of continuity
of it is so important.
So I think that, to me,
it's part of my heritage.
And I'm fascinated by the
country and what opportunities
the food ways and the
cultural food ways,
sort of how they
have been presented
and how they can play out.
I think it's very stimulating.
I never get bored of it.
I spent most of my life here.
The moment I get
off the airplane,
and I smell the orange
blossoms, and hear
the country and the
people, and taste the food,
and smell the spices, and
discover something new, which
happens every single trip.
I went five times last year.
There were 30 points in those
five trips where I was like,
I can't believe I've
never seen this before.
I am so excited
about this thing.
That never ends.
And as much as I sometimes
feel so not Israeli there,
I feel a sense of
peace in the bolygon,
in the craziness that is Israel
that I will never get tired of.
I was born there, which
means that even if I travel
in the Middle East on
my American passport,
it still says I was born in
Israel, which doesn't get you
very far in the Middle East.
But I'm really hoping--
this is super cliched, but I'm
hoping that, through food, we
can start to open up the
borders a little bit,
figuratively and literally.
It would be really amazing.
I would love to be able to go
to, which I can do, go to Spain
and make that sort of trek.
But I would also like to be
able to go to Aleppo, what
is left of it, and see
it; or go to Damascus;
or to go to Beirut; or
travel through the Beqaa
Valley in Lebanon.
Those countries are
super important.
And the fact that I
don't have access to them
is infuriating, quite honestly.
So hopefully, through
food, we can do it.
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you so much.
SPEAKER: Well, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]